les champs elysées demain matin
offriront sans doute cette image de
planètes civilisé mais abandonnée pour
la première fois depuis 29 ans le 14
juillet son défilé ont émigré aux
aurores demain les troupes prendront
place dans les petites rues qui mènent à
la place de la bastille où tribune et
estrades se sont dressés depuis dijoux
de la bastille à la république le défilé
du 14 juillet va ainsi retrouver les
boulevards populaire qu'il fréquentait
déjà au début du siècle obligeant
l'omnibus madeleine bastille a stoppé
son va et vient 14 juillet égale
bastille même imprécis sept têtes de
chapitre de nos manuels d'histoire est
dans tous les esprits
seulement les anachronismes alors sont
pourtant fréquents elle commémore la
révolution de juillet 1830 met longtemps
à la place de cette colonne il ya eu la
citadelle la bastille le 14 juillet 1789
elle était encore là et puis le 14
juillet 1789 le peuple de paris l'a
enlevé la supprimer l'histoire et en
1790 les révolutionnaires ont voulu
purifier l'air représenté par la surface
couverte par la bastille on a voulu à
helvea temple à la liberté
et ce n'est qu'en juillet 1847 et
redisant prêt 1830 qu'on a élevé sept
colonnes sous laquelle sont enterrés les
cadavres de ceux qui ont été tués en
juillet donc cette colonne en fait d'une
tombe alors vous savez qu'il ya deux
colonnes à paris il ya la colonne des
beaux quartiers
la colonne vendôme avec un empereur au
sommet et il ya la colonne du paris
populaire qu'est la colonne de juillet
avec au sommet vous le voyez un homme à
monsieur très nue avec des ailes dans le
dos une étoile sur le front un flambeau
et des chaînes brisées et c'est le génie
de la liberté le 14 juillet et la fête
de la liberté
et puis deux